how big is the business now I you guys
have raised what like 400 million
dollars
yeah we've raised 400 million uh we we
last traced Capital at 3.6 billion
dollar valuation
um I think there's still you know a lot
of potential for health monitoring I
think if you fast forward 10 years I
think
um a large percentage of the world's
population will be wearing a continuous
health monitor and it'll hook into
everything that you do as it relates to
the Health Care system and doctors and
um and so yeah I'm very bullish on on
the opportunity in the space
[Music]
foreign
do you uh do you know what you're
getting into or what I've read the
briefing and uh uh I'm a big fan of the
podcast so ready for you all right so
like the the Pod it's called my first
million it's kind of known for uh Sean
and I have both started a handful of
companies and sold a few of them and
people like the Pod because we
brainstorm and we dive deep on different
companies and we do like business
breakdowns things like that so but we'll
spend a little bit of time kind of
getting to know you because you've done
a lot of amazing things well I know I've
wanted a huge amazing thing that you've
done but I bet you there's a lot more
amazing things that you've done but
we'll hear a little bit more about your
background and then I'll then we'll want
to spend time like kind of diving deep
on different opportunities in your
industry but first like if you want to
like say like kind of like your your 30
second Spiel of like who you are and the
story of how you got there yeah
absolutely uh so well Ahmed I grew up on
uh North Shore of Long Island I as a kid
I was kind of always into the sports and
exercise I ended up going to uh Harvard
and playing squash in school and I was a
competitive College athlete and I felt
like I didn't really know what I was
doing to my body while I was training as
an athlete so that got me very
interested in physiology did a ton of
physiology research as a student I read
something like 500 medical papers and I
started to conceive of this idea of how
you could continuously measure the human
body and the idea was initially around
athletic performance but broadly I felt
like there would be ways to continuously
measure the human body for all sorts of
Health implications and uh you know what
became as a sort of a curiosity
ultimately turned into a very long
research paper that I wrote and then
ultimately founding a company uh this
was would have been when I was 21 22
years old
as a senior at Harvard and and then for
the last 10 plus years or so I've been
uh I've been building this this business
uh the business whoop builds wearable
technology uh really to improve People's
Health we started with the best athletes
in the world and and over time have
grown to work with a large consumer
population and uh and it's a really
exciting time to be building that that
technology
okay so yeah you're the CEO of and
founder of whoop uh if people have seen
it it's a whoop band you've uh you have
to have seen it on people's wrists but
you said something like we started with
high-end athletes and I think I read
something like this that is this right
that LeBron and Michael Phelps are two
of the first hundred customers or users
of whoop is that is that real and how
did how did that happen
that is real and this would have been
around
2014 2015 so you know we spent about two
to three years really on the initial V1
of whoop and
you know I wanted to start with the best
athletes in the world and really for two
reasons the first was that we were
bringing sleep and Recovery technology
to market for the first time and I felt
like professional athletes who uh you
know have to perform on a daily basis
should really understand how they're
recovering that was one of the insights
to starting the business
and uh and then second of all if we
could get the world's best athletes to
where uh whoop and organically like it
then we could build a whole brand around
uh performance that ultimately could
could scale to to Consumers and and I
grew up very inspired by
um Brands like Nike and and the Jordan
brand and and just how
like a swash on something could make
make the whole product feel completely
different independent from anything else
about the product uh just because of the
the storytelling behind it or the brand
behind it so I was interested in how
health monitoring Could Have A Brand to
it and uh and so that was really the
thesis for targeting professional
athletes and uh and so in the case of
getting to LeBron and Phelps the I think
the key Insight was finding people in
their lives who had a big influence on
them who a bunch of people didn't
already know you know if you go to their
agent or their manager or their wife
like they get inundated with this stuff
so you have to find someone in their in
their life who other people don't know
and it also turned out back then that
the personal trainer was a somewhat
under rated or unknown person in a uh a
professional athlete's life and that
also happened to be the right person to
go to uh for technology like whoop so in
the case of uh Lebron I got to know Mike
mencius in the case of uh Phelps we got
to know Keenan Robinson both of which
were personal trainers to those athletes
and got them on Loop and then they got
their athletes on Loop and
um yeah the rest is history how big is
the business now I you guys have raised
what like 400 million dollars
yeah we've raised 400 million uh we we
last race Capital at 3.6 billion dollar
evaluation
um I think there's still you know a lot
of potential for health monitoring I
think if you fast forward 10 years I
think
um a large percentage of the world's
population will be wearing a continuous
health monitor and it'll hook into
everything that you do as it relates to
the Health Care system and doctors and
um and so yeah I'm very bullish on the
opportunity in the space
do you like uh being the CEO of a of a
big company
um or do you wish do you like still wish
that you were in the early days of like
getting in the nitty-gritty because I
imagine you're like
kind of just making decisions now and
managing people as opposed to maybe
getting your hands dirty on the product
well I've still tried to stay close to
the product because I think it's
something I've had a uh a relevant
perspective on even as a company has
scaled and I've been able to see around
corners in a few areas for the product I
think that
the role of being CEO as you guys know
changes a lot with stage and scale right
like
uh 10 person versus a hundred person
versus 500 person like at each of these
inflections your your role is definitely
changing
um
I think because whoop as a technology
gets increasingly interesting with scale
it's made my role increasingly
interesting as well so
what do I mean by that you know the
overall data set uh that you have on on
a larger population makes the data much
more predictive and much more powerful
the coaching as a result can get much
more comprehensive I think for other
Founders I've met who have been building
a business for five years or even 10
years they get to a point where they're
kind of like
okay this can run itself or I'm going to
bring in someone new or I've kind of
reached the relative peak of the
mountain and I don't feel that way I
feel like there's still uh a bunch more
levels to go I feel that uh the insights
that the Technologies they were able to
get the number of people that it can
potentially use by all that feels like
it's amplifying not shrinking and and so
for those reasons yeah I'm very excited
about about being CEO it's also look
it's a daily challenge growing into it I
feel like at every stage of the business
I've had to learn how to uh how to be a
CEO and it's not like this is the first
just the first company I started it's my
first full-time job so you know I'm I'm
figuring a lot of this out as I go
Sam always asked that question and I'm
just waiting for the one person who's
like I hate being CEO I hate my job I
hate all these people that are in this
office this is terrible
there's certain things that change a lot
right like you you're
the percent of time in which you think
of yourself as an individual contributor
versus a manager has to shift very
dramatically uh I think probably around
the size of 50 people it has to shift
like that like it was about 500 people
but
that's probably one of the most painful
things that if a Founder doesn't fully
appreciate or recognize they can screw
the business up a lot
like you have to recognize that you need
to be shifting almost entirely towards
manager and not being an individual
contributor
well you know what it is is
we uh we we talk to a lot of interesting
people here and
the CEO of like a 500 person plus
company usually looks like [__] not
always but usually like they look tired
and there's Rings under their eyes and
they're usually a little chubby and it
takes a huge Swig of coffee oh no they
look like crap but you're a uh you're
like the CEO of a fitness brand you you
were a highly competitive athlete and so
you look great and so it's like you're
you're you're kind of like skewing the
the uh the average here but like I mean
you're like pretty fit is are you like
how are you balancing like being healthy
and putting your but also putting your
company first because I like when I was
really in the thick of it I was like
dude I don't have time to work out like
screw it I'm just gonna eat this crap
but uh you don't know this but one of
your competitors was my neighbor and we
used to work out together in my garage
every day and then uh and then he got
promoted to CEO he was like he was like
a different exec got promoted the CIA go
and then uh stopped having time to work
out like he just kept coming by while I
was that's what I'm saying and he was
like God I gotta get back in here and
we're like dude you're the boss you know
you could just like rearrange your
schedule right he's like I got crazy
it's crazy right now oh it's crazy right
now and for like nine months straight oh
it was crazy right now and he just
stopped working out I was like bro you
run a health company like you gotta if
you don't sleep or work out or make time
for this stuff like you know what's
going on here and uh I just thought that
was so funny like the the fact that he
was like you know no we have to make
this successful in order to do that I'm
gonna make these Health sacrifices as I
go what super nice like him I mean dude
Will's got like a chisel jaw you got a
nice head of hair you're wearing a it
looks like a like a vest you look all
you look all spiffy and you look nice
and [__] uh what what are you what are
you doing to exercise right now and how
are you balancing that with work I think
it look I think it's part of the the job
for me that that I'm gonna be in in good
shape and healthy and uh I spent a lot
of time around people that are super
into their health and fitness whether
it's professional athletes or scientists
or even thinking about product features
that are designed to improve your health
so as a business like just thinking
about the the product and technology
that we build every day that kind of
orients me at least to be uh to be
healthy and not to mention I'm using a
product that uh is all about health
Improvement so you know for a variety of
reasons it feels like it'd be super off
brand if I was uh if I was really out of
shape or or what's your like sleep score
when you sleep are your uh you know you
give us your give us your stats and also
what are some things that you know a lot
of this audience who listens to this
um I would say probably I would guess
the majority don't regularly wear a
continuous health monitor
um but also the majority care about
performing well Peak Performance and as
an entrepreneur typically
um who's listening to this so what are
some things that they a that you you've
learned that you know they maybe should
be doing or you know some of the biggest
levers that you've seen when it comes to
you know kind of health and performance
well I want to be clear that that uh I
do believe
building a successful company
uh requires overcoming some level of
stress that would break most people so I
I do think you have to uh really push
above and beyond what is comfortable
I think the technical term is man up
will yeah okay Mana
I think there's a lot I think there's a
lot of techniques that you can develop
for yourself that
um allow you to run it at a Breakneck
pace for a long long time you know
people always talk about this analogy of
okay it's not a it's not a Sprint it's a
marathon but if you actually look at
like world-class marathoners
they're running like four minute miles
or 30 miles it's kind of a Sprint
yeah so you know and how do you run a
mile that path so I think for the
entrepreneur or the you know the the
business leader listening to this you
want to figure out a way that you can be
sprinting a marathon for a long time and
and one of the ways I view that is
taking care of myself and and uh being
in good shape uh
I think we can start with uh uh sleep
which uh is is it I think a topic that's
not talked about in the right framework
most people when you talk to to them
about their sleep they're like yeah I
don't have enough time I'm working hard
blah blah
the thing to understand about sleep is
it's all about the percentage of time
that you spend in bed getting high
quality sleep
so if if you ask your your audience or
you ask a friend who's never worn a
health monitor
and you say how much did you get last
night he'll be like oh well I went to
bed at 11 I woke up at six I got seven
hours of sleep pretty good okay the
reality has been seven hours in bed so
of those seven hours
you were in a period of a wake a period
of light sleep a period of REM and a
period of slow way to sleep
awaken light are pretty much irrelevant
you're not getting any physiological
benefit from being in uh awake or light
stage sleep
REM and slow wave that's where all the
magic happens so REM sleep is
and your mind is repairing it's like
real cognitive repair
um it's when you have deep dreams so if
you're someone who can't remember dreams
or you don't seem to have dreams you're
definitely not getting enough REM sleep
any High performing exec entrepreneur
you need REM sleep
um slow wave sleep is when your body
produces 95 of its human growth hormone
so just think about that for a second 95
of your human growth hormone gets
produced during this stage of sleep
you're not getting stronger in the gym
right or working out you're breaking
muscles down you get stronger during
slower sleep so the more you get to that
the better okay and
let's take the person who spent seven
hours in bed
that person could have gotten a total of
30 minutes of REM and slow wave sleep
or they could have gotten a total of
five and a half hours of REM and slowly
sleep
like that's a like a massive massive
difference that's a huge Spectrum the
person with 30 minutes I guarantee you
has all kinds of problems in their lives
the person with five and a half hours I
guarantee you is very happy very high
functioning and what's like um what's
like really strong if an eight-hour
block was you know I'm in bed for eight
hours what would be like a good level of
REM and slow wave sleep if you can get
over 50 of the time you're spending in
bed to be uh REM and slow wipe sleep
like you're you're doing pretty well uh
and so I I I'm in that camp and and I'm
also still optimizing my life more to be
uh a CEO or an entrepreneur than a human
right if I was just fully focused on
being a great human I would probably
spend eight to nine hours in bed right
and I wouldn't look at my phone before
but and things like this right
um but because I'm still optimizing for
being an entrepreneur I uh you know I
spend more like seven hours and better
you know seven and a half maybe if if I
get a little extra sleep but I've
managed to make that time you know like
the three to four hours sometimes even
four and a half hours of REM and slow
wave sleep so I'm getting the REM and
slow wave sleep that like a a person who
might be spending eight or nine hours in
bed is getting because I figured some
stuff out that makes me sleep better
so that that's sort of one whole
category right there which is sleep and
anyone listening to this should try to
figure that out for themselves because
it's it'll just dramatically change the
quality of of your life I'll give you
another hack
I wear these blue light blocking glass
before bed and they've got a red like
kind of a red tint to them and uh if you
think about
laptops uh iPhones whatever all of them
are emitting this light that is telling
your eyes and your brain to stay awake
and uh if you're like me and you're
using your phone or reading an email you
know closely before bed
uh because you know you're you're doing
work or you're staying on top of things
uh it's gonna affect the way you sleep
but if you wear these glasses it's like
a get out of jail free card and you can
look at all that stuff right up until
the moment you go to bed and it won't
affect your sleep
so uh so that's like one example of of
how you can hack both sides of it
have you um you said you've been around
all these uh interesting athletes and
you also have access now to like
millions of pieces of data who are some
of the biggest freaks in nature that
you've been around
is there like Judy in Iowa that's
getting like nine and a half hours of
slow wave sleep and she's your hero you
got like a picture of her on your wall
yeah or like uh like all these athletes
that you've been around like is there
anyone who you just like you've seen
them in real life because they're like
Mutombo incredible yeah well you're like
we first started working with LeBron
James this would have been
uh 2015 2016. his sleep data I could
probably point to the one that was
LeBron's
which is kind of amazing like uh and it
makes a lot of sense that that he was so
good at uh and has been so good at
recovering in his career because he's
taking care of that third of his life
and and sleeping great I think it's
maybe the most REM and slow wave sleep
of anyone I I've talked to
um named Alex Honnold do you guys know
that name
is from free solo yeah yeah the climber
the climber right so this is a guy who
who uh you know climbs mountains without
a rope essentially and uh and does these
insane Feats that are extremely
dangerous
so the interesting thing about uh REM
sleep is researchers were able to find
the more REM sleep you get
the less heightened your amygdala
response so your amygdala response is is
fight or flight you know that's what
signals to your body to to to be nervous
or to to get animated so it makes a lot
of sense that the guy who's capable of
climbing uh you know rock climbing these
environments that no one's done before
without a rope
uh has this insane ability to sleep
because that's probably in part what
makes him so calm uh as he's doing these
activities so I thought dude I just I
just Googled uh Alex's name and then REM
sleep I think we just gave you the promo
of the century man like this is this is
the marketing this is like it should be
it comes up the first thing that comes
up is like a TED Talk not uh your
company talking about how you sleep more
you get more REM sleep then you're able
to like take a little bit more risk and
be calm I mean that's like a really
that's like a really interesting
um uh play here why not on those
athletes do you think it's a sort of
like intentional thing like you think
that they you know like is LeBron or
Alex are they doing something that's
making their sleep that much better or
do you think because they happen to be
great sleepers that a lot that is what
allowed them to become such great
athletes and such great performers
I mean there's certainly there's
certainly genetic things that make
people better or worse than sleeping but
uh there's also so many things that you
the individual can do to enhance your
sleep
uh sleeping at a very consistent time so
going to bed and waking up at a very
similar time we'll just
um we'll just unusually Elevate the
quality of of your sleep often sleeping
in a very cold room a very dark room a
very quiet room a room of high air
quality athletes who are serious about
this stuff will you know measure all of
that and dial it in I still think
athletes aren't sophisticated enough
about sleep and Recovery given how
important it is to their overall
performance
but those are a variety of things you
can do we talked about blue light
there's certain supplements that work
better or worse for people magnesium
melatonin interestingly hard harder
harder sleep drugs like the ambience of
the world uh they they knock you out so
your sleep latency is short but the
quality of the Sleep uh is never that
high so again back to that percentage of
time that you're in rem and slow wave it
it is rarely you know maybe if you're
someone who'd normally be at 30 you're
going to be at 20 percent
dude I've uh I was a a 400 meter Runner
division one Fortnight runner in college
so I used to be like fairly competitive
and I knew a bunch of basketball players
yeah and I knew a bunch of basketball
players who ended up going to the NBA
because I I was friends with them in
college
and uh dude it's shocking how bad myself
included how bad most competitive
athletes are when it comes to like a
diet and Recovery like I didn't know
anything I just like I would eat like
Ranch and pizza every day and uh a
couple of my friends who went and went
went on to play in the NBA like we're
just eat McDonald's like on a regular
basis it's pretty amazing how like some
people are still freaks even though they
don't do any of that nonsense you know
uh it's pretty wild and we've worked
with a lot of athletes like who
yeah they used to play video games from
11 P.M to 2 A.M
you know you got a game the next day in
front of a million people
you know and it doesn't occur to them
that that actually is going to affect
their performance
and then you look at the data and it's
like okay you're you've got a red
recovery even though you didn't even
drink alcohol because you stayed up late
staring at a screen
whereas if you you know had gone to bed
at the same time they started playing
video games here's the difference in
what your your performances
Sean you gonna make fun of me or
something no I don't know I was gonna
ask actually uh this is a personal
question naps where what's what's the
word on naps because I am a prolific
Napper in fact one of my life goals is
to be able to take a guilt-free nap
every single day and uh I know athletes
are pretty big on naps as well
but I don't know if you could get to
those deeper stages in a quick you know
in a one or one and a half hour nap uh
what's the word on naps
remember Winston Churchill of you to
have a daily nap that would yeah that'd
be pretty good yeah that's a that's a
good way to put it yeah yeah
like he's the coolest he's the coolest
person I can think of who who really
pioneered the daily nap as a as a
hardcore uh uh yeah it's a hardcore nap
I'll I'll I like that I think that
sounds better because my nap marketing
is pretty pretty soft right now I need
to I need to up it I need to have a
Churchill nap in fact I'm gonna brand it
as I'm gonna brand it as a Church Hill
nap dude I I do it every day as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah about two o'clock
for for about 30 or 40 minutes every
single day and you get in bed or you
just lie on a couch kind of thing no I
only go Sean you go to bed I only go to
bed for nighttime sleeping and then I I
refuse to lay in the bed I go to a
different bedroom I have a nap bedroom
and I have a master bedroom
really yeah interesting and you wear a
sleep mask or anything you just close
your eyes I wear a sleep mask but I get
knocked out like I wake up two hours
later and I'm like I'm a whole different
human being I feel like wait and you
could sleep at night after two hours I
can't do two hours two hours is a real
nap
yeah Churchill is that really what you
do you do two not every day but that's
my goal my goal is to get that to be an
everyday thing right now it's in every
third day Sean it's like here's my life
advice young man you gotta get a solid
16 every day life's cream cheese
I'm not a big nap person personally I I
almost rarely ever take naps but I think
that they're certainly uh plenty of
research that shows that for most people
getting a nap versus not is gonna make
them uh feel better and uh perform
better I certainly think a lot of
athletes uh take them in the afternoon
or even some will take them almost right
up to the time before tip-off or when
they when they have their their uh event
so and they because I think one of the
reasons for them is they also need to
Peak in their performance much later in
the day than most people right so like
an NBA game might start at 7 30 or 8 and
they're playing until until 9 or 10 or
whatever and so but whereas most people
are winding down at that time but they
so they kind of need to shift their
their Peak Performance later in the day
whereas most entrepreneurs are trying to
be you know Tip Top at 9am or whatever
yeah I think that's right the challenge
with naps is that the percentage of time
that you spend in in uh trying to sleep
is often lower as a quality standpoint
so that's why I was kind of interested
in whether you guys get in bed or
whether it's more casual because you
might up the intensity of the setup of
your nap to really maximize the the
quality of the sleep
to try things like sleep mask or try you
know a couple little things and you
might all of a sudden feel even better
after your nap
are you the only founder
are you are you a solo founder
well I I was fortunate in that I met two
really talented uh Engineers when I was
graduating from Harvard so uh one is uh
John capilupo who for 10 years was our
chief technology officer and the other
is a really Nikola he's still with me
and he's our uh Chief mechanical
engineer uh and the combination of of uh
the three of us uh really built really
built the company now uh
a lot of it was algorithms development
you know computer science data science
having the right
um prototypes and yeah so it was it was
uh it was very technical out of the
gates
well what um
um but you're you're the the you
consider them co-founders or just uh uh
meaningful uh contributors
consider them co-founders I mean I I
came up with the the idea for the
company uh uh you know years before I
met them but but they've been an amazing
I mean amazing piece of of the whoop
story and critical
what do you um so you're the CEO you're
you're uh and founder of a multi-billion
dollar startup what what do you do with
uh I assume I don't know if you're
liquid or not
um or if you have a lot of your Equity
so tied up what are you gonna do with
all your money when you eventually do
get liquid uh do you have like any big
aspirations are you just like a boring
guy who just like when I've taken
secondary along the way any secondary
yeah I have I have it's uh
well look it doesn't it doesn't actually
change your your motivation all that
much in building the business that was
something that I remember
someone's saying to me uh at various
points when I had the option to sell
some shares and
uh I think it's really just made the
quality of my life higher and you should
post your sleep before and after the
secondary be like do I sleep easier at
night now by the way 50 million in the
bank yeah it turns out I do actually I
do sleep a little easier at night taking
secondary I remember when I was first
getting going in my career and I heard
about these secondaries and I was like
that's [__] I think it was rooted a
little bit in Envy but I also was like
you got to be all in and now that I've
like done a little bit of stuff I
realize having a safety net and this is
like a very obvious thing to say so I
sound like an idiot here but having a
safety net particularly like a
meaningful safety net of of liquid net
worth I think 100 makes you better at
building your company and I think taking
secondaries it changes on a scale
sometimes it's too much but taking
secondary I think will make you a better
company Builder do you agree with that
I do especially if you're like a growth
stage of company I don't I don't think I
ever sold shares until whoop was
worth at least a billion dollars
um and they were for Rounds that were
super over subscribed
so I but I do think that's a fair I
think that's a fair lens to look at it
from I've read about people taking
secondaries at the you know series a
stage or something and
I don't know everyone's I could look
everyone's circumstances are different
so you don't want to you don't want to
judge but
um I do think for a company that's at a
later stage where you're trying to
you're making this calculus is this a
company that's going to be acquired in a
short period of time or is this a
company that we're trying to build to be
a standalone business and I think if
it's more the latter you want your your
Founders or your key your you know your
CEO you want you want folks like that to
be uh not sort of looking at their bank
account wondering when they're going to
cash out on this thing you want them in
a mode of and I can keep going for a
while uh and you know really optimize
the business so yeah I agree I agree
with you what do you do with your money
do you just do like boring uh Vanguard
uh or like index funds or or or do you
do something a little more risky and
what do you like to spend spend your
money on
I wouldn't say I'm the biggest spender
of money
um but I I mean I've enjoyed investing
in stuff investing in startups meeting
Founders I've enjoyed uh backing stuff
that my friends do uh or start
I
if you go out to dinner with your
friends do they just bill comes do they
just sort of look at you and wait now or
uh oh yeah they got they got T-Rex arms
suddenly that that wingspan shortened up
big time couldn't even get to the pocket
anymore
no I mean look I think it's uh
it's great of course to be able to be
generous too and and uh take care of
people or cover bills or whatever
um
I I think it just sort of creates a
peace of mind for you and in an
important way if you're gonna be uh
trying to do something for the next 10
years
what companies did you want to start uh
before that because I'm looking at your
background so you said you're from Long
Island you live in in Boston and went to
Harvard so that's amazing but you
studied economics like you it didn't
look like you had and then you worked at
a bank right or you're just like an
intern at a bank you were I know my
wife's from Long Island it look you're
going down that's a very typical path of
just being some like Banker type in in
the city uh but you kind of like took a
left somewhere what uh what other
companies were you thinking about
starting
I wasn't thinking about starting
companies at all actually and and your
observation's right I sort of I thought
in the back of my mind I would go work
in finance after I graduated because
that's what a lot of people seem to do
and
uh and I had some background in finance
because my dad had worked in finance
but you know internships are a great
thing to figure out what you don't want
to do
so I worked at a hedge fund after my
profession here I worked at an
investment Bank after my sophomore year
and I worked at a private Equity Firm
after my junior year and the question I
asked myself at each of those places is
you know did I want to be my boss's boss
her boss's boss's boss or uh you know if
I could be one day and uh
and I just didn't I didn't feel that
pull I didn't feel this like
gravitational pull towards it and uh at
the same time I was becoming sort of
obsessed with this idea and I think I
ultimately became an entrepreneur before
I really knew what an entrepreneur was
it wasn't like I was choosing between
three or four different ideas it was
just this one idea that I became
obsessed with
well in the last uh decade that you've
been doing this you know any
entrepreneur I think sees other
opportunities you see things that are
pain points for your business that
you're like man somebody should make
this easier or you'd meet a bunch of
other entrepreneurs and you realize oh
wow there's like a whole universe of
potential businesses that that can be
started and be successful
um a lot of people listen this podcast
to try to get ideas to think about oh
what what's what's possible what's
possible what could I be doing right now
and um so do you have any uh business
ideas that have come to you you know as
you've been running whoop that you're
not going to go do because you're
running but like you know maybe somebody
else could do it
I have a lot of sort of funny tangent
like business ideas that are uh sort of
silly business ideas that you you know
think of uh I'm in the shower or whatnot
uh and so we can we can rough on some of
those and then I have you know I have
some that are more don't don't tell us
which ones are the serious or the silly
we probably will get them all mixed up
ourselves anyway so take one off your
list and let's let's hear it
okay this is a very funny one so the the
idea for the company is is carb pipes
and it's uh it's vocalist lessons while
you're commuting in the morning so
you're in your car and you've got
someone who's teaching you how to sing
and you know you're you're uh carpet
yeah you're in a safe space so you could
you could you can belt it out
exactly so those are the types those are
the types of ideas I feel like that I
think of a lot I'll give that one I'll
give that one a b Sam
uh F I think I I always wanted to sing
look dude you you have so much listen
you have so much data so I both are
having car pipes no it's stupid you're
you're you're a brilliant man and you
just had one dumb idea I'm allowed to
say that you both Sean and I have both
invested in a continuous uh glucose
monitor companies
um I don't know I don't know if you ever
I I think I had an opportunity to pass
on your company will or somehow a deck
made it my way and I and I was a fool
and I didn't do it or maybe I just
didn't have any money I think that's
what it was I think I think I just
didn't have any money I think I was just
I just didn't have enough cash
um I mean I want to know like which of
these wearables do you think are gonna
be awesome and which wearables in the
future are going to be uh
are gonna be a thing you know on the Pod
what we've talked about I don't have a
background like you so I'm just kind of
riffing here but I've always thought it
was ridiculous how you can have like a
cancer or something bad inside of your
body growing and uh you know I've had
family members who have passed away and
it was like you know had we just gotten
this MRI or CAT scan like six months ago
you would have been fine and I've always
thought it's very strange that something
can be in your body and it's just a
matter of you just didn't get it
measured uh otherwise you would have
been you could have been fine I've
always thought that to be quite strange
and whoop actually told me one time when
I had covid and I thought that was sick
and I'm like well sick you should tell
me if I have like cancer as well you
know what I mean uh that's that's a
that's something that's always
fascinated me yeah and I would put I
would put all that sort of in the
category of like uh obvious Innovation
that's coming
um the combination of body scans blood
work and continuous monitoring through a
non-invasive wearable
um will ultimately be able to predict a
lot of things that that uh
you know are disease States or or uh
leading indicators uh for death
and so I'm very optimistic about how
profoundly uh the healthcare space the
relationship with your doctor I mean all
of that will change it's which so so
obvious and then the other thing is and
and artificial intelligence is a very
popular expression these days but AI
will be enormously valuable for uh
analyzing a lot of uh a lot of these
some more complicated scans uh to look
for things inside your body that might
be off
which otherwise required you know an
expensive Radiologists to look at or
something
which startups do you think that are at
like the sub 100 or sub 50 employee
count and maybe sub 300-ish million uh
market cap or uh valued uh like below
that do you see in the health health and
wellness and anything related to that
category that you think is going to have
a similar trajectory as you guys and has
a bunch of uh meat on the bone for for
growth and upside you know it's funny
because I I think I've spent so long
thinking about health and wellness it's
almost like the bar to invest in a
health and wellness thing is is too high
so I actually find that I don't invest
in all that much related to health and
wellness like I'm racking my brain right
now I think of something that I'm
involved in that's and that's directly
Health and Wellness
a related company that I think is quite
quite powerful is called whisper which I
am an investor in and it is uh they've
essentially built technology that allows
you uh that can transcribe uh your
thoughts which is is
pretty powerful technology if you think
about it uh the ability to sort of think
something and and it gets written out uh
so I really like deep Tech stuff like
that that feels
feels like magic feels like the future
and how that how does it do that you're
wearing like a brain scanner device type
thing and then you literally think
something and it writes it how what
happens I don't want to butcher this but
the the short of it is it looks like you
know an old Jawbone might have uh one of
those Bluetooth uh sets and and that's
you know that's what the Technologies
form factor looks like you literally
just think something and it writes it or
you have to like sort of whisper it
uh uh I believe it's using your brain
waves what's the URL of this
uh it's whisper.ai okay I just saw it it
looks like a little uh it looks like a
like a hearing aid yep
oh that's cool how much money have they
raised you know
uh I wanna say something in like the 15
to 20 million range wow that's pretty
fascinating
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
so here's a category of work that's a
little more serious
obviously you guys have seen uh
everything that's come out in terms of
deep fakes and this ability to create
videos of people that
are almost indistinguishable from uh
from a real video right
I think that there there's going to be
like uh a talent agency of sorts that's
for non-living people
so you know imagine if you're uh if
you're Tom Cruise towards the end of
your career
the same way Justin Bieber just sold
like the rights to his songs maybe Tom
Cruise sells the rights to Tom Cruise
and you can keep making movies with Tom
Cruise for the next 100 years or
another version of that is you can have
uh an actor like Tom Cruise who's
completely artificial
have you seen the Tom Cruise deep fake
on tick tock
totally it's
incredible it's the same have you seen
this thing yeah it's amazing you know
who did that Sean we talked about it uh
[__] uh the South Park guys is that
deep Voodoo or that's somebody else I
thought it was deep I thought deep
Voodoo did the time Tom Cruise what am I
wrong Miles Fisher Miles Fisher oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah and uh he's the one who
doesn't I think it's him and this other
guy because he kind of looks like Tom
Cruise but there's a whole technology I
think that doesn't even need a human
involved which you know would just
essentially take the fact that Tom
Cruise has made 50 movies and be able to
yeah but that's interesting you're like
instead of selling your back catalog
sell your future catalog basically so
you can sell your likeness to your light
you could create a AI likeness and just
license it out to whoever wants to you
kind of use it which is obviously has
some you know some potential like you
know ways it can be misused but seems
valuable enough where people would
figure that out have you guys heard of
Michaela I think her name's uh is the
name Michaela the Instagram influencer
who doesn't exist you know what I'm
talking about yeah yeah it's like a
model that is completely made up right
yeah yeah but now but now she's got like
a boyfriend I don't actually know if
they're together or not anymore but
she's got like a whole cast of
characters now and I've been getting
into it and they raised a bunch of money
and like she's getting ad deals it's
super fascinating dude it's super
fascinating and what's more fascinating
is I think that if I if I had to guess
the way that they're making the the way
that she looks they're using AI to come
up with like the ideal
uh like the ideal person that both men
and women are attracted to or like want
to like follow and be into and I follow
her boyfriend and he's super skinny and
he's little and drag like androgynous
and I'm like
[__] they don't like yoke boys anymore
like you know these and so it's kind of
funny to see like what they're like
making is like the ideal person it's
very fascinating but the business is
making a lot of money I believe well on
this pod a while back I had said uh
somebody needs to create a deep fake
only fans model because I was like oh
you could just have a virtual only fans
model that even kind of looks a little
virtual that's okay and now this is just
a money maker for you right you're like
basically like some sort of virtual pimp
if you created these these AI only fans
characters and a guy did it so so a guy
reached out and um and so he created it
he's like he basically used his
girlfriend who's like a model or
whatever as the model for it and then
created a AI clone of her and now we're
like setting it up and we're gonna see
how it goes so I'm really curious to see
if this thing like takes off or not
so are you actually interested in this
business are you are you gonna be oh my
God this is uh so interesting to see if
this works or not
yeah but like
how do you work with like
softcore porn all day I'm not doing
anything I'm just like getting the
update he just DMS me and says check
this out and he'll be like you know we
got the account made or we're gonna you
know he'll start sending me updates on
how much money they're making right I
just want to see how it how the
experiment turns out I don't have to sit
there and like train her
think about the investor updates that
will sends he's like you know here's
like screenshots of our new prototype
you know like we've effectively we've
we've gotten uh people's REM sleep to
improve by five percent by just adding
this little feature here's a mock-up and
they're like What's it gonna look like
to you
it's gonna look great I don't know I
don't see what the problem is
well that's that's actually a
so a theme that I think about is like
okay 50 years from now what are things
that
the the future generational look back at
our generation and say oh that was so
crazy that that was happening then like
there's a lot of easy versions of that
for us
today right where it's you know you can
say smoking on uh you know smoking on
airplanes or
um
you know the number of people that died
giving birth or uh
you know uh people dying from just
traveling across the country right like
so there's all these examples of that
and then if you try to pull it forwards
what would they say about things that
feel sort of a little too normalized
today
and yeah what what are things that your
grandkids will say like really Grandpa
like you know slavery and you're like I
don't know it was just the norm back
then right like what are those what are
those things today that 50 years from
now will seem
either like crude or rude or whatever in
some way right like I think the health
monitoring is an obvious one it's like
you just didn't know
how you were doing and it's like yeah we
just didn't know you go to the doctor
once a year maybe and like yeah they
just randomly measured my blood pressure
once a year right that was that was my
checkup that's that's to me the most
obvious one that will seem like wow you
guys were really capable you just rolled
the dice with that one huh your whole
your whole Health thing and that that's
just going to be so different in the
future
the number of people that die from car
accidents
seems like it would be on that list
dude I was driving last night on a late
night like two one lane road and a huge
truck went by me and I it shook my car
and we were both going 80 miles an hour
like you know passing each other and it
does seem in about 20 years it's gonna
be so archaic we're like can you believe
that we are basically one sneeze away
from like an 80 miles an hour like car
crash all the time like you just just
literally 10 feet away five feet away
sometimes it it that is good that's
gonna be that's Gonna Be Our Generations
smoking section in restaurants that that
cars two cars going that's really it's
gonna be like smoking or non-smoking
like you used to drive these cars going
in opposite directions and you were 10
feet away from each other that's what
it's going to be like I think and like
my wife is vegan and she's like yeah
like that the thing that's gonna be you
know the 50 years from now is like you
just killed animals and ate them
like what what why like that you just
thought that was I bet it's like dude I
bet Will's got a total opposite take out
here yes that's what I wanted to hear
what's your take on uh sort of like
vegan carnivore plant-based you know all
these different you know ver more
extreme versions of diets have you seen
anything or where where's your head at
it was the data say around that
the data says it's highly personal uh so
you could put two people on identical
diets and they could have literally the
exact opposite effects on those on those
people I remember uh I mean take
professional athletes for example that
you guys remember when LeBron got really
skinny it was like around the Olympics
yeah and it was you'd been playing with
Ray Allen so Ray Allen got him to go on
the Paleo diet
and because Ray Allen was obsessed with
the paleo diet and again it's an example
it was amazing for Ray terrible for
LeBron like terrible uh and so there's
every version of that for uh for the
rest of us for me personally I.E uh
I ate three meals a day I try not to eat
crap uh I eat carbs I I've you know I
would say I have like a Mediterranean
type diet a lot of meats and fishes and
vegetables
um I don't really drink that many
calories mostly drink water and coffee
so so that's my diet I also think diet
is easier if you like the right things
and then you can kind of eat as much as
you'd like or as much as fills you up
versus having to
count calories in part because a lot of
the calories you consume are really bad
calories so those are my quick
perspectives on diet
dude have you seen well have you seen um
Brian Johnson do you know who that is
yeah the uh uh he created a really cool
or is creating a very cool company
um that measures brain waves yeah yeah
but have you seen blueprint
well that's his whole age reversal uh
he's like a human he's like a human
whoop band
yeah yeah he wears whoop and uh and so
that's how I know him and uh he's come
on the podcast before I think he's
coming on actually soon is his uh is he
like in the is he in the top like one
percent of of data because if not
he's doing a hell of a lot of [__] with
his lifestyle if that doesn't work if
that doesn't give him some off the
charts readings on his uh on his sleep
and his his strain then I don't know
well I want to be clear that I don't
have access to every single person on
whoops data but but uh I think some of
the stuff we went over because he was on
a podcast maybe a year or two years ago
and he was telling me some pretty good
stats then and it sounds like he's
dialed it in even more sense so I'll
definitely listen to the podcast you
guys through them well so listen to this
Sean this just happened I think this
morning it was released so basically he
was on our pod and he looks like a freak
you know like he's like chiseled he
looks awesome and I don't know how old
he is actually he's like yeah yeah but
he like he's he's looks great and but
you know he does all this insane stuff
that you'd expect a billionaire to be
able to do he's got like a 30 doctors
like helping him do all this he's he he
you know whatever well it just released
that or it was just released that you
can spend I think like a lot like a 1.5
or 2 million dollars a year and you
basically can he's gonna like anyone can
use his doctors and go through his
system in order to what he's trying to
do for the listeners is he's basically
it's kind of like this thought exercise
but he's taking it seriously which is
he's trying to reverse his age which you
can do through like improving your blood
and losing weight things like that so
reverse his
biological age faster than his
chronological chronological age goes up
because in theory if you do that you
live forever obviously that won't happen
but it's like an interesting like
thought exercise but now anyone can sign
up and apply to use like all the crazy
[__] that he's doing you're gonna do it
Sam
it's like two million dollars a year no
um also like I have a here I have a
thing with all the fitness people and
Brian I I called Brian out for this and
he actually answered it well but I'm
like do you ever experience Joy like
like like
like so I don't drink alcohol and a lot
of people say like oh I've been wanting
to do that and I'm like well do you have
a problem and they go no I just thought
I've been like then what like it sounds
dope then just get drunk every once in a
while that like you know that's like a
that's like a life worth living is like
when you have things to celebrate and
like you can build camaraderie with your
friends like yeah just do it you might
live a little shorter you might be sick
for a few days but like you know like
experience Joy that's good and so with
Brian I was like Hey do you ever like
have birthday cake for your kid's
birthday like do it he's like no I've
only cheated like once one meal over
like two years or something like that
and I was like well you happy and he
said I'm happy so my opinion of as okay
great you're winning but for most people
I don't know experience Joy a little bit
like be healthy and also like get effed
up every once in a while
I think that's good advice will I have a
I have a similar thing that you'll just
you'll you'll hate slash disagree with
which is uh on my Twitter I have this
tweet that's pinned that just says
here's some semi-controversial things
that I believe and one of them is
um you don't need a sleep tracker great
sleep is obvious and uh I think you
would probably disagree because it's
kind of the premise of your life right
now but
you gotta admit pretty catchy and
there's some nugget of wisdom in there
there's some nugget of Truth in that in
that belief just because it sounds good
doesn't mean it's true
yeah I mean I think that might be true
in like extremely binary terms you know
oh I had to wake up for a 4 a.m flight
or uh you know uh
the the alarm kept going off last night
like yeah okay those are bad nights of
sleep but I I think it's it's a profound
lie in the sense of if you're actually
trying to understand your nightly sleep
and routine like I think there's just a
lot it's a think about it this way it's
a third of your life that is a complete
Black Box you have no idea what's
happening during that third of your life
and and science has proven that that's a
third of your life that dramatically
affects the other two-thirds and if
you're good at sleeping it decreases
every form of potential disease that you
can have
like it is the magic pill so
I don't agree with your Tweet but I
respect
tweets tons of Retreats right
we do it for the retweets around here
and uh
I I do think that that Sam's points are
good what good one though as it applies
to a tweet which is
if you make all these things seem
you know like discipline in spite of Joy
or or sort of soulless uh then
then of course there's some kind of a
rebellion against it right and so I've
heard people talk about sleep tracking
in a way that makes sleep tracking seem
profoundly not cool and and so I
understand it through that lens but I
think the reality is you can measure
things about your body passively that
give you a great insight into you into
your life and make your life better
right
yeah okay so what do you think's gonna
happen well 10 years what's your what's
the what's the vision here you're gonna
go public you're gonna sell this for 10
billion dollars what do you think is
going to happen
I think we'll ultimately go public uh I
think that it'll probably be sooner than
that time frame that you gave and I
think we're gonna build technology
that's able to predict a lot of massive
life events uh as they pertain to your
health and
and along the way provide a 24 7 coach
that uh helps people meet their goals
well beyond Health you know
psychological goals professional goals
uh just because of the the value that
understanding your body can provide
dude you've stuck it in the face of all
the finance Bros you're saying I didn't
have to go that route and I still
crushed it I think that's awesome I've
got so many New Year friends and they
just in uh Long Island friends and they
do the same thing over and over and over
again I'm like you're selling your soul
man this is the worst and uh it's so
cool that you kind of saw that route is
not maybe for you and you you're gonna
just crush it uh we're big fans of whoop
um I've never tested the aura ring so
I've been loyal to to my whoa uh I've
been calling it I call it whoop and
whoop so my apologies I actually didn't
know the right way to pronounce yeah
what is the right way
food
I could like kind of like whoop too
like I would never say I'm a whooping
ass
today so you know like I kind of I don't
know yeah
the founder of it or Sam yeah what do
you know
if you wear it inside out it's whoop
yeah
I never knew how you pronounced it but
my wife and I have our our paid
subscribers how much should we I think
we pay you 300 a year I don't even
remember dude I paid you for two years
and I just didn't have my band I lost my
band and then I just kept the
subscription going so you know you're
welcome on that one but now I got my
band back and now I'm getting the value
yeah yeah if you reach out to membership
services they'll send you a band no
problem
if you're a subscriber the Hardware's
included I mean that was one of the more
that was like obvious now in hindsight
but uh in 2018 we changed the whole
business model to being a subscription
where the hardware was included how much
was that like a huge I mean your
economics drastically change
totally I mean we used to sell the
product for 500 one-time fee everything
included then we went to you can sign up
for as little as thirty dollars like
picture the just all the cash
implications gross margin implications
everything that happens almost overnight
when you do that and it was also about
the business moment because okay
companies founded in 2012. if you're
changing your business model that
profoundly six or seven years later
you're also admitting you haven't
figured out the right business model six
or seven years into building a company
so uh
yeah that was all that was all quite
quite uh
painful and concerning but we you know
we created a really cool business model
that that now has been amazing yeah now
you're gonna get maybe you can make
you're gonna make an argument I don't
know if you're gonna get it but you're
gonna make an argument that you get
those SAS multiples yeah and then I
think there's a fair case for that yeah
I don't know what your churn is but
that'd be that'd be badass because I
mean that's that's you know five times
more valuable company
um
well dude this is awesome yeah thanks
for coming on we took you a little over
time sorry about that but uh but thanks
for coming on will this is this is fun
and uh yeah everybody go get some sleep
and by the way Sean right from you
that's a big pivot well I I said great
sleep is important I just said great
sleep is obvious
uh you know directionally you know which
way you're going whether you track it or
not and then once you get once you get
going in the right direction then start
measuring it and optimizing it did you
have a Twitter thread that was killing
uh clubhouse
get him that blood is on my hands yes
wow that's yeah
how's that what do you think
on point and all the clubhouse investors
who blocked me because they thought I
was just being a hater you know the um
my door has a little mail slot for
apologies and uh they're welcome to go
ahead and slip the slip the apology back
in yeah no I'm connecting the dots on
some tweets of yours that I've I've read
now uh because I also remember that
sleep one I think about it
that was my version of the of the
clubhouse thread for you
uh I don't know that business very well
but it certainly seems like it's uh not
doing as well as it was in the middle of
Kobe well I think what a hypocrite Sean
is by the way he's got he owns a whoop
yeah whoop whoop he owns a he owns a
loop and he's still saying you don't
need a sleep tracker that's [__] man
call him out will yeah well I I
definitely will now
well I'm waiting for the version that
like just Auto charges or like stays
charged for like two years so I can just
leave it on because uh I'm a notorious
lose [__] guy so you know I'm on my 18th
airpods I uh you know I've gone through
three whoop bands and uh it's the
charging that gets me every single time
same what's the plan dude is a 30-day
charge gonna happen anytime soon or is
it for a guy to get an infinite battery
around here
yeah just do better and by the way the
the modular battery pack I think was a
good Innovation at least so you don't
have to take it off but but uh
you know originally I was hoping we'd be
able to do it like watches were there
certain watches first movement yeah keep
it alive the reality is that because we
collect so much Health Data we're
driving the battery pretty hard and the
sensor is pretty hard so
uh in some ways it's great that we've
gotten to four or five days but but uh
customer feedback heard okay we'll work
on the two-year model for both of you
no that's been my same thing which is
that's why I don't wear an Apple Watch
is I think it's so stupid that you have
to charge those things all the time I
think dude I lost my wedding ring on my
honeymoon because I just lose everything
same I had I got mine tattooed on my
hand because I lost it so much
I'm not smart enough to get away with
this absent-minded Professor [__] where
it's like oh he's so messy but he's
brilliant it's like he's you know you
know above average it's like that
doesn't have the same doesn't have the
same uh you know excuse power for me
that's all right you're you're good
enough that you can screw up every once
in a while but uh yeah the battery thing
man you guys got to figure that out but
we have
I think we have Will's email in the
calendar invite so Sean you just gotta
you're just gonna message him hey Will
lost my band
please hook up thanks right
I will delete mail I'll delete tweet
affair
well losing it because they wear it all
the time so you must be taking it off
too I got also got little kids and my
little kids are like oh bracelet toy you
know they just think it's the theirs and
so they just steal it when it's charging
on the counter and they now I lose it so
you know whatever well dude thanks for
doing this um
your uh your PR guy John is my good
buddy John uh hooked us up with um
uh Ariel helwani you like UFC uh Ariel
and John are good buddies and Ariel's
like the face of like UFC journalism he
hooked us up with that he made the
introduction to you so uh we we owe him
a shout out but I appreciate you coming
on this is awesome are you big UFC fan
oh yeah we both are yeah we're both huge
into it are you uh I'm not a huge fan
but I mean I observe it uh from a
distance I I think the athletes are like
you know some of the more uh impressive
physical specimens in the world
yeah besides the whole brain thing
besides that
they gotta put that away that's
just what I
I slapped dude that is the dumbest thing
man on the slap League what that is so I
wanted to be here I watched three
minutes of the preview and I was like
you
just when I thought I was out Dana White
you got me backing
dude that is the dumbest thing ever are
you really are a fan of that no one's
saying it's I think it's adorable you
know and they get knocked out so for
those listening who don't know we're
talking about it's basically I think
they have weight classes but it's
usually always like the big old fat guys
looking like they're supposed to be
strong but they look huge and they just
stand in front of each other and they
smack each other five times right is
that the rule it's five slaps and but
they almost always get knocked out it
looks like yeah you just take turns open
hand slapping each other but the slap is
like a thud it's not like a slap it's a
basically a punch and uh yeah it
basically results in a brutal knockout
like every every single match which is
pretty crazy it's and then their faces
are so swollen have you seen that like
when their jaws are so small dude and
they wear earplugs because they will
rupture your eardrum you know if you've
ever gotten hit in the earlier Sam did
you see the trailer for it like they
released the preview that was like
supposed to Hype you up introduce the
league and they're like these people
come from you know everywhere they come
from nothing this guy was doing this now
this has given him this opportunity and
he's still alive and then one guy goes I
just want to change the world man
change the world
one slap at a time brother what are you
doing we're democratizing slap
Chris Nowitzki who's done all this
concussion research uh uh at Boston
University is one of the the key guys
from for doing concussion research in
the NFL he
he was in the WWF wasn't he he was like
a professional wrestler yeah and he had
a bunch of concussions and uh and he was
like it's it's just half a step from um
having people just stab each other on
live TV and then saying who makes it
yeah we should also give get ratings
right there's this idea of pain
fatainment you ever heard this term
it's basically I get the idea of it from
yeah it's a great great name for that
reason right which is we love
entertainment of people suffering you
know and so like whether this is TV
shows like Survivor or Naked and Afraid
or whatever where they have to suffer in
that way or it's somebody suffering uh
in an emotional way when you're watching
Dr Phil or Jerry Springer and somebody
finds out they got cheated onto their
Maury tells them they are not the father
whatever there is a you know they used
to have executions publicly and people
would come and watch the execution
literally like you know whatever in
France in the old days and so there's
this long history of people enjoying
stuff watching suffering uh as a form of
entertainment and uh it's this crazy
thing but it's it's something that that
does exist I'm not saying it's good or
bad but like uh
I do think it's uh I do think it's gonna
work for that reason
there's some Darkness there yeah
well thanks for making this happen dude
we appreciate it yeah this was fun
thanks for having me guys yeah we'll uh
we'll be in touch because you know I'm
gonna be emailing you all my complaints
about my warp but uh and maybe I'll be
one of your investors whenever you IPO
but this is awesome and we appreciate it
do you uh you can give a shout out by
the way what's your do you use social
media at all well I'm at her are my
handles
well thanks for making this happen we
really appreciate it we'll talk soon
they will talk soon guys cool
[Music]
thank you